[Music]
you've heard about this Andy and you've
all heard about this bullying of
redheaded kids it's a something that's
being dude it's not funny don't snicker
about that like haha those freaks well
I'm against bullying but that particular
kind is fine well there's been some
stories in the news about you know
people bullying redheads and it really
hit home with me okay for obvious
reasons and so I called up the good
people at Sesame Street and I asked them
if maybe to help this problem to help
stop it maybe Elmo could make a public
service announcement that would teach
kids that redheads are people too it
seemed like a good idea yeah I called
them up and apparently I have more pull
in this business and I thought right cuz
Sesame Street made the public service
announcement I haven't seen it yet let's
take a look I know some people think
having red hair is different or strange
but I was here to say that having red
hair is really cool just look at all
these cool people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
a scary
[Music]
[Applause]